okay so Greg yes you have a Super Bowl
commercial and he's two ribs in I know I
don't know I'm all over the place here
because I'm very excited you know the
thing is
uh I always thought I would be playing
in the Super Bowl
Jason this is the next best thing but
Tom Brady he's home oh you know they're
at Sarah High School alumnus this Sarah
High School alumnus is at the Super Bowl
in the Super Bowl in an ad while you are
in your underwear doing selfies for only
fans
disgusting disgusting could I talk about
Rihanna real quick yeah and that's
um you know halftime has become
something for people who don't like the
Super Bowl right so it's becoming more
and more jarring more and more oh
flamboyant over dramatic it's like
having a seven course meal and stopping
in the middle of it for a lap dance
which is so stupid nobody has the lap
dance while they're eating so my point
being this is like I really would love
to see it kind of go back to the way it
was
um but then to the ad and then I'll shut
up it's gonna be seen by 40 million
people this ad and we don't have a clip
because we want you guys to watch but
so I all I keep thinking is who are the
people that haven't seen me since I was
a kid like kids I went to school with at
grade school yeah the ones that picked
up me and then I'm thinking about all my
romantic flames right girls are you
gonna remember well I mean I know I
can't wait to see it I can't wait to see
how Taylor reacts because she's got like
we haven't spoken since the breakup
right yeah
how do you like me now yeah exactly
there's gonna be some kids that look to
Mommy and go he looks like Daddy oh boy
oh my gosh
like you can't pick up this at home but
this whole place it smells so good yeah
it's like a barbecue
commercial break oh dear tell us about
the energy in Philly yeah it was crazy
um you know when you're doing it foxy
Prince you got to be up at 4 30 a.m so
to walk in there and I understand what
you know if the Cowboys were at the
Super Bowl I would be on 10 every single
hour of the day but these people are on
10. they're they are Next Level I have
never witnessed fans so energetic
energetic it's going to be sad if they
lose though because what are you going
to do with all the rest of that energy
and I and I actually like Patrick
Mahomes as well I think he's going to
use the Texas I think he has a lot of
strength but uh we'll see what happens I
kind of felt like the owner was just
kind of messing with people right
because he had a bad you know his ankle
wasn't great and then he took off that
last play against the Bengals I'm gonna
look like your ankle but he also said at
the end of that interview he goes look
you know you he's not 100 but he's but
he's also the MVP yeah so he that's how
he covered his tail on that interview
judge you're going to be watching yeah I
am couldn't be watching I have a fashion
show ahead of time but I'll be back to
watch it but here's the thing Greg you
know you think that the halftime show is
an interruption of the game I think the
halftime show is the game okay I mean
I mean I can't she has
like her life
it's in like seven years four years
seven years yeah I love her I think
she's great and I love that they've got
a country music guy Chris Stapleton
singing the National Anthem and uh in
case you want to know uh I am a I'm a
Chiefs fan because I love my homes and
the other thing that I want to say about
this is that mother that uh Kelsey
mother Travis and I mean what a lucky
woman she is what she must be an
incredible woman to have raised two sons
to have the discipline the perseverance
the strength and the talent to be both
in the Super Bowl they're like a
straight version of the Property
Brothers
all the spectacular athletes and the
people who traveled so far to get there
and I mean their career is not
geographically but the two brothers
you're talking about this is gonna be
the first time in Super Bowl history two
brothers have ever played against each
other I'll be thinking of their mom
because that's gonna be amazing you have
to clap for every play
um 24 year old quarterback versus a 27
year old quarterback that is going to be
the ultimate showdown I'm super pumped I
like the game and I like the halftime
show it is alive at first in the game so
it's the first time you have two
brothers facing each other it's the
first time you had a coach that coach
the other team that is now coaching and
it's the first time you have two black
quarterbacks facing each other as well
so a lot of it's awesome can we love
that can we just point out that the the
person we should be thinking about is
Trey Gowdy because uh Sunday night in
America is on
during the show just flip on over and
say hello to Trey Gowdy because you
never can get enough of his Charisma his
Sleek features and his ominous owl like
Maine which always changes I was gonna
say it's never the same she has
beautiful hair and we'd love hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else